una moratoria mundial en la vacunación
es el pedido de la organización mundial
de la salud a los países ricos el
objetivo que retrasen hasta septiembre
la aplicación de terceras dosis para que
todas las naciones del mundo logren que
al menos el 10 por ciento de su
población esté vacunada y why land
mientras cientos de millones de personas
están esperando su primera dosis es loud
son algunos países ricos están pensando
en aplicar dosis de refuerzo more than
el hacia el 80 por ciento de las vacunas
han ido a países de niveles medios altos
pese a que representan menos de la mitad
de la población mundial the world expo
gleision las dos realidades son
evidentes mientras la unión europea ha
aplicado dos dosis a más de la mitad de
la población y países como francia y
alemania esperan iniciar la aplicación
de vacunas de refuerzo en septiembre en
áfrica sólo el 5% ha recibido una
primera dosis en eeuu también están
preparados para aplicar terceras dosis
si las autoridades de salud lo aconsejan
ya pesar de que ya vacuna en
adolescentes este miércoles rechazaron
la moratoria propuesta por la o ms según
la casa blanca reforzar la inmunización
no impide la donación de vacunas podemos
hacer ambas cosas y no necesitamos tomar
esa decisión desde la organización
mundial de la salud insisten en que no
hay evidencia de que se necesite una
tercera dosis mientras que un mayor
avance de la vacunación en todos los
países puede ayudar a evitar nuevas
variantes por ello piden la colaboración
de los estados ricos para llegar al 40
de la población mundial inmunizada a
fines de año de hecho los países de
altos ingresos iban a donar este año
2000 millones al resto mediante el
mecanismo kóvacs sin embargo por el
momento sólo se han repartido 177
millones menos del 10% del objetivo